jean michel maire ont parlé votre
première mais on disait que vous étiez
l'intello de la bande et vous étiez
quand même déjà relou mais a préparé une
petite compil de lourdeur regarder
quelle mère c'est l'intello de la bande
et lui sinon un concept si les gens
qu'on on ne se comporte pas en meeting
comme ils ont honte il le montre à des
millions de téléspectateurs c'est comme
qui dirait on d'un petit et qu'il fasse
tomber ça c'est ce qu'on tombe bien
c'est comme le mec aurait on la voit une
petite [ __ ] qui passe son temps mais
cessons france
vous savez d'ailleurs ce que la demande
au père noël zahia non les 2000 euros
comme aux autres sur le site de c'est
quoi l'amour carole répond à peu voté la
spectatrice et j'ai noté une question en
a une qui demande carole est ce que
comme le dit syntec l'amour c'est
regarder tous les deux la même direction
sur à quoi que j'ai été un peu étonné
nous a répondu non ça c'est là le bret
en sage est en france quand j'étais
tellement lourd qu'à un moment il ya
jamel debbouze qui vous a recadré
j'adore cet extrait suis laissé dire par
quelqu'un qui travaille dans le milieu
de la publicité et ça fait un peu rebond
film intouchables qui vient de sortir et
qui fait carton qu'on connaît qui est
une marque de chocolat très connu et
commence par ba qui termine par nir qui
vous a proposé d'être l'égérie de la
marque faire une pub avec évidemment le
jeu de mots pas bras pas de chocolat et
que sa fille fait un écho dernier moment
ça a capoté
vous êtes mieux
on ne se relâche pas jamais j'embrasse
mon père est mort voir la tête et de
jamel parce qu'on voit pas je vois là et
que ça a failli se faire écho au dernier
moment ça a capoté
[Applaudissements]
vous avez quand même des invités
prestigieux est ce qui au départ ils ont
tous dit oui alors non non non non je
remercie d'ailleurs denis brogniart qui
était premier devenu samuel etienne t
effet le pilote et après ça s'est
enchaîné voilà d'ivoire mois en janvier
benjamin venez mathieu est venu y avait
on avait une annulation
voilà oui oui à propos de jean-michel
faut quand même dire qu'à l'époque de
france 4 justement c'est là on a
découvert sa vraie nature de séducteur
on va dire ah ouais moi je me souviens
très bien qu'après une émission alors
lui il est sans fil non mais cette
anecdote folle a raconté on a dit qu'on
se disait tout on sort du plateau c'est
très peur c'est ce qu'a dit non on a eu
peur
vincent jean michel bret on l'appelle on
lui dit ben si tu fous il décroche il
dit moi j'arrive j'arrive chez en dix
minutes on l'attend salut après on voit
une jeune fille sortie au nom du peuple
et à minutes après on voit jean michel
suau outre mais on ne s'habille et on
lui dit mais attends tu es sur ton ou ta
tête tu donnes
non mais ce qu'il faut c'est que ton on
lui dit mais tu viens de et là nous dit
oui on lui dit mais tu décroches
vous m'appelez moi je vous réponds non
donc le mec très bel été où la joie
pardon je m étais pas tant la loge où
l'info ce qu'à l'époque de france que
vous avez des locaux celui vous n'en
avez plus moi j'ai une anecdote à nous
raconter sur une chaise j'ai jamais
raconté c'est qu'un seul objet un jour
il a fait une caméra cachée
ah ouais pour c'est mon choix il a été
dans une loge ce qu'ils savaient pas ses
cloches gt3 face caméra il devait se
faire piéger
mais il est pas venu tout seul dans la
loge nom et imaginer les gars dans le
camion régie gomis elle sait pas qu'il
ya des caméras partout une meuf dans la
loge rappelle effrayer cyril on a un
gros problème aurait dit de quelle
taille 24 cm cfoot et comme jasper non
mais je vais pas les images on les a
punis
je vous ai dit voilà je vous dis tout
c'est vrai ou pas cette histoire à bas
bien sûr j'avais peur qu'on voit les
images c'était terriblement pour la
jeune fille mais voilà à qui je donne
même si cours de journalisme
[Applaudissements]
il faut dire que c'était votre masse non
mais c'était maintenant vous êtes venus
aux mains sur ses stars du moment
séducteur il a la cote c'était pas ma
meuf la veille ses neuf longues balles
jaunes a cédé ma meuf effectivement mais
je la donne beaucoup jean batailleur
allez vous soyez un peu gentleman bien
sûr mais je la vois toujours oui bien
sûr donc dire au multi cette fois c'est
vraiment encourageant à tout jamais et
que ces sectes chaussures pas toujours
non mais parce que moi je vois là je
prend la vie du bon côté et j'essaie
d'être sympa et voilà donc je les
respecte et je suis toujours sympa avec
alex est mon ex femme avait quand même
vous saouler tout le monde la nasa